وبينما زرعت الالغام وتحصن القرم هناك هدف
اخر عين على الشرق معركه قديمه جديده
والتركيز سيكون بالقرب من دنياك القصو حدث
بالفعل بالقرب من باخمود وابدبيكا
بحسبنز مجموعه روشان
عددت فوائد اما مثل الانسحاب من خرسون نقل
الموارد بعيدا من الجنوب وتعزيز قواتها
على طول خط الجبهه الشرقيه بلغه الارقام
50% من القوات المسحبه من خرسون يمكن
نقلها لجبهات اخرى لسليمان جمباز لكن هل
تصمت اوكرانيا
لا لديها توجهان تحاول بناء مع حلفائها
نظاما دفاعيا جويا متكاملا تريد حمايه
سماءها والاستعداد للشتاء الذي يقترب وهدف
ثاني وهو محاوله نقل القوات الخاصه بها
الى زفوجيا منطقه اخرى كانت روسيا اعلن
الضمها رفقه خرسانه اذا غنيمه حرب ربما
غريبه انسحاب روسيه من مدينه اعلن قبل
اسابيع ضمها ودون قتال خرسانه مع اوكرانيا
مجددا الزمن
حقق لاوكرانيا ما لم تحققه المعارك
الانسحاب الروسيه من خرسون رغم الحديث انه
كان خطه وصفه انصار بوتين انفسهم في
الهزيمه الاستراتيجيه الابراج
قرروا انسحاب القوات الروسيه من خرسون
الاقليم الذي ضمته موسكو مؤخرا الى هيكلها
جاء وفقا لخبراء عسكريين لعده اسباب منها
اولا صعوبه احتفاظ موسكو بهذه المنطقه
بسبب انعزال القوات الى حد كبير على
الخطوط الامداد وعدم امكانيه دعمها ثانيا
لتجنب الاخطاء التكتيكيه التي ارتكبت خلال
الانسحاب غير المنظم منخارف ومنعه وقوع
ضحايا بين القوات واعاده تجمعها وتدريبها
للاحتفاظ بخطوط المواجهه الحاليه القرار
كان صعب لكنه عقلاني هكذا وصفه بعض
المسؤولين الروس مثل الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان
لكنه لاقى انتقادا من المتشددين منهم
وعلى وجه الخصوص الفيلسوف القومي الروسي
الكساندر دوجن الذي شبهها تسليما مدينتي
فيرسون بتسليم اي مدينه روسيه اخرى
ورغم التقارير عن خطه بوتن لكن الخيارات
امامه لم تكن كثيره الانسحاب الضروره لا
تقبل التاجيل 10,000 جنديا في الضفه
الغربيه من نهر
باتوا شبه محاصرين منذ تدميري
شرياني حياتهم الوحيد وبحلول الشتاء
تتضاعف احتياجاتهم من الوقود والمعدات
ويحول دون وصولهم اليها حصول كيف علامه
فعاليه بعيده المدى النهر والجسر
والمدفعيه الاوكرانيه
اشهر ولم يتم تعويض الخسائر في الافراد
والمعدات في الوقت المناسب ولم يبقى امام
القياده الجديده الا امرا وحيد التخطيط
لانسحاب المنظم جعل اوكرانيا تستعد
المدينه لي يشبه الامر
بانزاله النور
القرار الروسي بالانسحاب من خرسون تراه
اوكرانيا انتصارا لها وتصفه القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه في البلاد بالقرار
الاجباري نتيجه لهجوم المضاد للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه التي اخترقت خطه دفاع
روس في خرسون بسبعه وثلاثين كيلومترا
واستعاده ما يقاربوا الفن
2381 كم مربعا منذ بدايه اكتوبر حتى اصبحت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه على تخوم
المدينه كما قامت المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
بقطع طرق الامداد والطرق الاستراتيجيه خلف
خطوط الروس الامر الذي اجبرهم على
الانسحاب في هذا التوقيت حتى لا تقعوا
القواته والمعدات والاليات العسكريه
الثقيله فريسه لحصار الجيش الاوكراني
السؤال هل انسحبت موسكو بلا خطه بديله لا
لديها بدائل تضاف ولما ذكرته سابقا بل
وبمزه التكلفه اقل الجيش الروسي الان بصدد
بناء خطا دفاعيا ثابت الشرقيه النهر الخطه
تهدف الى تجنب الخسائر طيله الشتاء
وامتصاص قوه الهجوم الاوكراني وتجميد
الحرب سيسمح ايضا بتحضير الجيش للمرحله
القادمه وبما ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هجينه
وتلعبوا على مستويات مختلفه مواطن اخر
حاول بوتان فيده بالانسحاب من خرسون وهو
افساح المجال امام الحربي الاقتصاديه
والهدف استهدافه ذخيره دعم وربما الرغبه
في مواصله تقديم التضحيات سحاب وروسيا من
مدينه خرسان العسكريه يعني الكثير خطط
وتطبيق مدينه ميكو لايف والتقدم نحو اديسا
بما يسمح بعزل اوكرانيا عن البحر الاسود
سقطت في الماء على الاقل تاجلت حتى الربيع
موسكو كانت تعمل ابي ببناء ممر بريا الى
منطقه ترانس نسريه الانفصاليه في مولدوفا
حيث تقع قاعده عسكريه روسيا الرئيسيه هناك